Look at what Gaza looks like. Was there Hamas everywhere? Cuz
it's flat Okay.
>> This is This looks so bad for everybody who supports
Israel, right? This looks awful. This horrible optics. All the
all the all the parents Is that your argument? Is that all these
kids that died, these innocent children, their parents are Hamas?
Are you serious? What are Okay, this guy's crashing out. We need
to save his career. Do not play the pick-a-side Adam when it
comes to 20,000 children dead.
>> Adam Sosnick has lost his mind, okay? You guys may be
unaware that Adam Sosnick has totally lost his mind. Generational
crash out from Adam Sosnick has been continuing on the PBD podcast,
all right? And I don't think many people are tracking this, but
he has continued to crash out day after day after day after day.
We covered this last night, like very late last night, so I did
want to come back today and cover it today because
it's very very very funny. It's very very very good. You know,
no one really knows what's going on. At the same time, while
this is taking place, Israel Israel says it struck over 200 Hezbollah
targets just in the last 24 hours. The Israel military said its
air force hit over 200 targets linked to Iran-backed militant
group Hezbollah in Lebanon on Saturday. The announcement of the
strikes comes as Iran demanded a [laughter] ceasefire in Lebanon
as part of the wider talks with the US in a This is after operation
eternal darkness, I >> I'm a bad to end the war in the
Middle East, Adam. You're talking about Lebanon right now? >> Yeah.
No, I'm talking about Lebanon. I'm talking about Iran's threats,
Iran controlling it, all those three >> Well, if you listen
to what Trump said, did you see the quote what he said? Listen,
we've already won. You see that quote? Can you pull that one
up, Rob? Yes. Basically, he says It's like Adam is on a quest
to prove that the way he talked during the Dave Smith interview,
even though he didn't normally talk that way. He's like on a
quest, or I didn't see him normally talk that way. He's on a
quest to prove that that was actually correct. >> the United
States is a terrorist organization. You've already lost the >> When
our politicians lie us into wars that slaughter millions of innocent
people, I consider that terrorism. I've run circles around you
on this, dude. Check the scoreboard. Most unpopular war in American
history going in. Check the scoreboard. 13 dead Americans, millions
of innocent people being displaced. >> You have the luxury
of sitting in your little studio with your hooded sweater, like
you're 17 years old. I have a wife and children. Who depends
on you, Adam? Your mom?
Okay. I also have a uh significant >> He's on a quest to
prove that that was actually correct. And you should just like
only do
salesperson talking points. You should never try to engage with
any topic. Did you see what Trump said? He said we've already
won. Okay, that's not an argument, man. That's literally declaring
victory while making no argument.
What are we doing? Yeah, I don't really care care what happens
in these negotiations. We've already won. Destroyed their military.
I think Trump is basically
doing this. It's a game of chicken about the Strait of Hormuz.
The Strait of Hormuz Like you have to understand, Iran has nothing.
You You blew up all their [__] You blew up everything,
right? You blew up all their [__] You have nothing
more to threaten them with now other than like genocide, other
than saying you'll kill you'll blow up all their power plants
and you'll make it so civilians can't even live there. That's
the only thing you have to threaten them with. And now they hold
all the cards because you have no more leverage to to use against
them. If you wanted to say, "If you guys don't do this, we're
going to start blowing up, you know, your military facilities."
Okay, that That could have worked,
The only thing you have left to do is to become Israel.
Like a a bigger version of Israel.
Look at how much your citizens like Israel right now. Is that
what you want for your future? Is that what you want for your
administration? moves What countries is that the most important
to? Let's get real here. Before this war, how many of us talked
about the Strait of Hormuz?
I talked about the Strait of Hormuz and the the Strait of Malacca
constantly.
Constantly because every single person who's taken a 101 in geopolitics
understands how important these two regions are. You're a if
you don't know that. Holy [__]
Yeah, you never talked about it cuz you're a [__]
Anybody who knows anything about this region or about anything
to do with global trade knows how important these things are.
Talked about Panama Canal. Talked about the Gulf of Mexico. We
talked about the Monroe Doctrine. We talked about or the the
the Trump Doctrine. Uh Don Road Doctrine, Strait of Hormuz doesn't
really affect the United States, does it?
It absolutely does.
US is another important point important point here just in that
yes, the the world manufacturing, global
is the state of the world. It's how things are so cheap. We have
global just-in-time manufacturing. When there are manufacturing
disruptions,
everything at the price of everything goes up. We learned this
during COVID when somebody turned sideways in the Suez Canal
and [__] everything up, right? If you make oil prices
go up for China, who manufactures so many things, that increases
the price of everything for everybody. Maybe it hurts other places
more. You can argue that, but it hurts the US a ton. It hurts
the US voter a ton.
Uh Don Road Doctrine, Strait of Hormuz doesn't really affect
the United States, does it? It affects certain other countries.
Pakistan, Jordan, Egypt, Southeast Asia, India.
So, I think he's using the the Strait of Hormuz as a leverage
point saying, "If we close this down, what's going to happen
to the rest of the world?" Didn't we have a picture over the
weekend of how much drilling is happening in the Gulf of America
now? How many ships and and uh oil drill refineries are popping
up and how many ships are coming through the Gulf? Did we not
Did we not discuss
The The whole concept of drill, baby, drill, drilly drill. It's
base You mean dig we must, dig we must? Is that Is that what
we're talking about, Adam?
It always bothered me that we're protecting and we don't need
them. We didn't need them before we started uh dig we must. I
dig we must. It's a Trump policy of lots of oil. He doesn't know
that it updated its name. It's It's dig we must now, okay? Dig
we must, dig we must. We got lots of It's a The The chickens
are coming home to roost. Now, regarding Lebanon,
you know how they say, "You know, Israel controls America. It's
Bibi Netanyahu controls America." Okay. Well, did you see Did
you hear what Anthony Blinken had to say? We can tee up that
clip. But you know who controls Lebanon? It's not even a question.
It's Iran.
Hezbollah is Iran first. This whole conversation, why would Lebanon
I mean, they're all Shia and it and Iran does fund Hezbollah.
In fact, Iran funded Hezbollah's formation. It's a Shia like
militia that was going to resist Israel pushing into Lebanon.
Sure. Not part of Iran. I mean, they're different people, but
he's saying that the funding comes through Iran. And it basically
always has come through Iran as far as I know.
Influence is not controls. I mean, influence is very strongly,
I would say. I don't have a problem with that. It doesn't mean
that they're culpable for Iran's actions.
It doesn't mean that.
be a part of these negotiations.
Cuz that was the center point. That was the linchpin as to what
JD Vance Did you see JD Vance what he had to say? And when he
was outside of Air Force One? He goes, "Listen, yeah, we were
going to trying to do the uh Dude, Vinny
Vinny's like freaking out through this whole segment as Adam
continues to just sweep for Israel for no reason. And it's so
funny.
I'm going to pause on Vinny. >> outside of Air Force One?
This is Vinny the whole time. Vinny is like so anxious. He's
losing it the whole segment at how badly Adam's just sweeping
for the dumb [__] He's like looking at the chat as
the chat goes The chat gets really anti-Semitic. I'll be real
with you guys, okay? The The The Valuetainment audience is not
happy with Adam. They're hating on Adam. And I feel like Vinny's
looking at the chat and how they're slowly turning on Adam more
and more and he is like losing his mind.
He's losing it, okay? So, Adam is arguing about how clearly JD
Vance and Trump are doing a strategy to use the the Strait of
Hormuz against their adversaries, even though it hurts Americans,
so they could And Americans don't care about those adversaries
being like checked right now. Like Americans don't want China
checked. Any checking of China requires actually hurting them
economically, which hurts America economically. So, people don't
even want that right now. It If China invades Taiwan, okay.
But realistically, as long as China's just being peaceful, nobody
in America cares. Nobody wants China like checked right now.
They don't want China [__]
Cuz any with China that you do increases prices for everybody
globally. You Did you see JD Vance what he had to say? And when
he was outside of Air Force One? He goes, to trying to do the
the the deal. And then all of a sudden, Israel and Lebanon are
going at it." Well, who started that? Who's doing that? Well,
there's That's been ongoing, but here's the point. He goes, "I
genuinely think Iran thought that Lebanon was part of the deal.
And Lebanon wasn't part of the deal. Lebanon's name didn't even
come up. So, Iran's playing games.
That why um that seems really unlikely given that the Pakistani
like prime minister or president, I forget now, came out and
said that Lebanon was a part of the deal. Lebanon was a part
of
Why would the third party, the the mediator of the interaction,
lie about this? It doesn't make any sense. They have their proxies
out But I have watched I have watched America come out and basically
take their cues from Benjamin Netanyahu and try to like basically
gaslight everybody after the fact. I've seen that happen multiple
I've not seen the Pakistani prime minister, Mr. Sharif, go ahead
and lie on behalf of Iran. Why? Why would he do that? out there,
whether it's the Hezbollah's, the Houthis, Hamas, Islamic Jihad,
whatever they're doing, they're funding them, not funding their
own people. Lebanon has no part of this deal
Lebanon is controlled by Iran. That's true. Are we sure about
that? Like how >> What's your proof that Iran controls
Lebanon? Okay. I mean, they could they have significant influence
over Hezbollah and they are aligned and
like as like basically Iran is the seat of power
for the entire [clears throat] Shia Muslim faith.
Like that is where that is the base of power for the the Shia
Muslims across the entire Middle East. And so Hezbollah is a
Shia militia. Therefore, Hezbollah is going to have some level
of connection to Iran to Tehran in general, right? To the the
supreme leader obviously of the faith. So No, I'm No, I'm asking
>> No, okay. No, I'm asking. >> What do you know
about Hezbollah? They're terrorists. Okay, where are they based
in? They're all over the place. No, they're not. Yes, they are.
Uh no, they're not. Yes, they're in Iran. I'm sorry, they're
in Lebanon. They are. Well, there's they're in Iran as well.
is based in Lebanon. Facts. Just like Hamas is in Gaza, just
like the Houthis are in Yemen. Okay.
>> As I'm hearing this argument form in Adam's head, as
he's saying it out loud, I'm like, "Oh,
where could you I can't see a good direction this goes in. The
terrorists are over there, right?
Yes, nothing ever You listen to somebody who's like Maga aligned
right now. The terrorists are here, right? Oh, you're about to
do something crazy, aren't you? You're about to say some totally
[__] insane [__] aren't you? And how
do they get [clears throat] their funding?
From Iran. The the Iranian terror proxy network. Okay, that's
who this Hezbollah
So rather than funding their own people, own economy, drinking
water, everything, they fund Hezbollah. This isn't even a controversial
statement. This is Wait.
They don't fund their own economy. Why do they have problems
buying stuff,
Hey Adam, why why does Iran, despite being massively rich, have
problem buying things for their people? Why do they have problems
importing water? Why do they have problems importing a bunch
of stuff? Adam. Adam. Adam. Adam. Hey hey Adam. Adam. Adam.
Why do you think that is? It's true. So they're sending in Imagine
you're in Tel Aviv. Imagine you're in Miami. Imagine you're in
New York. You're He he just doesn't understand that those conditions
of drought, of famine, of of anything that could be going I I
don't think it was a famine necessarily. It's really drought
was with them, right? Those conditions are preferable to the
US and Israel.
Right? They don't want to alleviate those conditions. They don't
want those conditions to be alleviated at all. That is why they're
having issues because those conditions are going to foment uprising.
Those conditions are going to foment like basically popular support
on the ground for them invading or doing something, right? That's
why those conditions were pervasive.
It was intentional.
sitting there and missiles are flying in over your city. I don't
think people truly understand what's going on in Israel. Their
entire country is living in bunkers at this point. Okay, when
when when Iraq and Iran were at war. Okay, you're you're a proud
Iranian I assume at this time.
I I assume you were hearing He was like, "Eight, man." What do
you mean he was a proud Iranian? He was like, "Oh, look, boom
boom, missile go boom." He was he was a he was a toddler. >> missiles
over your head nonstop. Do you remember this? Yes. Do you still
have like flashbacks about this? Oh, sorry, that's probably traumatic
actually. That's probably it's probably actually traumatic, but
And I'm not saying this doesn't go on in other parts of the world.
The entire society in Israel right now is underground. They get
to pop up and live their lives. All of a sudden, missiles are
coming from Iran, they have 10 minutes. Out of nowhere, just
missiles Guys, they just live in a world where for no reason
Iran fires missiles at them all the time.
no way. Adam, really? So like Iran Israel was just minding its
own business and then Iran just started launching missiles?
That's insane. to get underground. Missiles come in from Hezbollah,
they have 3 minutes to get underground. Missiles come in from
whatever left in Gaza, they have 1 minute. You've an entire Western
democracy ally of the United States, regardless how you feel
about BB in Israel. You have an entire society that is forced
to live underground cuz the IRGC and all their their proxies
are sending missiles >> clip by Blinken? Anthony Blinken,
this is a zipper conversation about What is a >> So this
is basically saying, how did uh US enter this war in Iran? And
he this is Anthony Blinken obviously former Secretary of State.
>> see it. >> Basically saying, was it BB? Was it
Trump? Whose decision was it? This is Anthony Blinken. Go ahead.
Prime Minister Netanyahu had very He thinks this helps. He he
thinks this helps. >> once tried to convince the Obama
administration, the Biden administration to do things like this.
To my knowledge, he's tried to convince virtually every
uh since he's been in office to do what President Trump finally
did. He came to the Obama administration and tried this. He came
to the Biden administration and tried this. And he finally found
a willing customer in President Trump. But this is President
Trump's decision. This wasn't BB Netanyahu's decision. It was
President Anthony Blinken, I I understand what he's doing here,
okay? The the real analysis we've done on this stream, okay?
We've already done the real analysis here. The real analysis
is
they had
a [__] in power. They knew it and they took advantage.
That's why everybody's going to be upset. That's why everybody's
going to blame Israel because guess what? Israel as an ally of
the United States is perfectly willing to exploit a total [__]
to get their way and go for the American people in the process.
That makes you a terrible ally, okay? You. President Trump's
decision. Look. That's it. It's not that previous admin What
was that sound? What the hell BB Netanyahu's decision. It was
President Trump's decision. Look. That's it. Oh, that was Adam's
voice cracking and him going boom. He was saying boom, but he
said it with his voice cracking. Did you hear that?
Did you hear that?
I'll turn it up for you guys. President Trump's decision. This
wasn't BB Netanyahu's decision. It was President Trump's decision.
Look. That's it. Boom. Boom. I can't even make my voice crack
that hard. That was insane.
Get this guy some tea. His voice is not doing well, okay? He's
having a rough time. He's had a very rough time since this crash
out. It's just been an an eternal crash out at this point, okay?
Not that previous administrations, whether it was This President
You have to admit that Adam It's 1,000% President Trump's decision.
Mhm. But you cannot sit here and pretend that BB Netanyahu doesn't
have major influence. Jared Kushner has [clears throat] known
Jared Kushner has known him since he was a child. His father
in New Jersey, he used to go BB in Jersey. He's over there negotiating.
That's a conflict of interest number one. Number two, Like people
don't know this.
Yes, Jared Kushner's known BB Netanyahu his entire life. I don't
know, people don't know this. They've been friends. I believe
I believe BB Netanyahu's described Jared Kushner as one of his
best friends. We can't pretend, Adam, everything was Iran Iran
Iran and then Israel went on full on seizing land and attacking
in Lebanon. And mind you, Adam, in heavily
uh populated civilian and Christian parts of Lebanon. And they're
literally seizing land. And it's looking now because, Adam, who's
to stop them from just going, "Well, there's terrorists here.
Bomb them." Who's checking to see how many civilians are dying
in in Lebanon? Who is doing that? Where's the Cuz if if if you
all you have to say is this, "There's terrorists there." You
could literally keep bombing, keep extending expanding until
you've taken over as much land as you want. Yes, Vinnie. Yes,
Vinnie. Yes. Yes, Vinnie. Vinnie gets it. Vinnie understands.
Vinnie seeing, okay? Vinnie has been red-pilled. Vinnie is seeing.
He can see through the matrix. He's like, "Wait, you've just
invented like a you've invented a justification that lets you
do whatever you want forever. Wait, we can't just let them do
this, right? We have to actually make sure they're terrorists.
We have to actually check something. We can't just let them do
this We can't just let them do this forever." Don't Obviously,
I want Hezbollah taken out. Obviously, I want Hamas done. Obviously,
I want ISIS done, which Trump basically did. But if you've been
seeing, like I've been seeing, literally in the downtown area.
You want to talk about Miami? I'm out in Miami, a whole apartment
complex with civilians coming all the way down and they're bombing
it. So that's what I'm saying is, Adam, there's a huge huge Christian
population there, which I'm not comfortable with them going on
full offensive when you're supposed to be focusing on Iran. I
get it. They can What's the saying that you said before? Walk
and chew gum. But it's like, bro, >> this? What is this
clip, Rob?
>> It's it's crazy.
Uh it's nuts. So Vinnie's just totally cracked. Like yeah, why
are you why are you starting another war on another front with
somebody you've crippled totally? You've totally hobbled. Why
are you doing this? And why are you going like, "Hey, we're knocking
this apartment building down in an hour. Get out of here. You
don't have time to get your possessions." Boom boom
Why are you doing that in Lebanon now? We already had problems
with Gaza. Why are you doing it in Lebanon after you got the
US to start a war with Iran for you? What what's going on here,
guys? What the [__] are we doing?
Yeah, I didn't love that he was like,
never forget, it's not just Muslims doing it to to this time.
Now there's Christians involved. What the hell,
Wait, what? Wait, huh? Shouldn't that be I mean, I guess I you
know what? Whatever gets you on board at this point. Whatever
gets you on board, man. Whatever gets you on the right team.
>> Yeah, that's all. This was the strikes last week in
Lebanon. Yeah, that's Okay, you want to kill one terrorist, so
you do that? Let's just say there's one Hezbollah guy in there.
Why would you say there's only one? I'm just saying, how many
how many there I I've heard justifications for some of those
apartment buildings coming down. And I don't think the justification
was there were any Hezbollah terrorists in there. I think it
was like they had arms stored in there or something. And so they're
going to blow up the entire apartment building. And that was
one of them. I don't know if it was this one. I don't think they're
actually striking terrorists, right? Because you can't even you
think about it. One, they have to give people evacuation warning
for that building. If they're just knocking that building down
without telling people to get out, like that
I say that, it would be totally monstrous. It's already totally
monstrous. I do believe they're giving evacuation orders saying
you have to get out of that building, right? They're telling
people you have to get out.
they have taken out a building because the 5-year-old grandson
of a Hamas leader lived in it. Well, it's like that, right? And
and so they let them get out. They're not even trying to kill
terrorists. This is terrorism. They're not trying to kill terrorists.
They say, "Well, actually there's a ton of Hezbollah munitions
and money in there, okay? And we have to blow it up." That's
what they say. And they give them a warning to leave. So, realistically,
okay, if it was money in there, can't they just grab that money
and walk away?
So, what have you done? You've just bombed an apartment building.
What is the functional What is the functional use of bombing
apartment buildings like this? Terrorism.
To terrorize.
That is the functional goal of Israel right now in Lebanon. In
Beirut, they are trying to terrorize the population.
Hey, do you guys Do you guys really feel any sympathy for for
Hezbollah? We're going to terrorize you. This is their goal,
right? Either you turn on Hezbollah, you turn around on the people
around you, you all become informants for us, and you like basically
kill these people and bring them or your their heads or bring
us their heads, or we're going to terrorize you forever. That's
the trade. That's what they're Take out that building. >> Cuz
I don't Are you telling me? Do you have reports? >> So,
I don't know, cuz they're I I appreciate your passion, and let
me let me respond real quickly. 30 seconds ago, you didn't even
know that Hezbollah was based in Lebanon. >> I didn't I
didn't say based I said they were I didn't say that. I said they're
>> No, they're not. They're in Lebanon, period, full stop.
You might say there's one guy who has a cousin who's hanging
out in a different part of town. Man, I heard they were in Venezuela
training the Venezuelan militias on how to fight, no? Or was
that Hamas? I can't remember. Was that Was that Hamas or Hezbollah
that they were trying to say was in
Hezbollah's in Lebanon, and this is exactly what it is. You just
said, "Obviously we want to take out Hezbollah." Yeah. So, kill
how many civilians for one terrorist? How do you How do you assume
that they do that? What do you mean? I don't Adam. >> How
do you think they saw what they did in Gaza and they blo- Dude,
Gaza Adam. Adam. Adam. Adam. You got to stop, Adam. Adam. What
do you mean? I don't Adam. >> Because I saw what they did
in Gaza and they blo- Dude, Gaza is flat. It's flat. So, they
killed almost 30 >> Vinny, you got to pick a side here,
bro. No, no, go, no, no.
>> Oh my god.
Isn't that crazy?
You got to pick a side, man. You got to pick a side. Gaza is
flat, Vinny. It's
Or sorry, Gaza is flat, Adam. It's flat. You got to pick a side,
man. Are you Are you siding with the terrorists, dude? You really
You're just going to stand with the terrorists? Really?
Re- Really? What are you going to You got to pick a side here,
man. Oh, I I have to pick a side, Adam? Well, convenient, because
I I have indeed picked a side, okay? I have picked a side.
I've I've picked my side.
I'm going to stand with humanity, and
you've put all of humanity on the side of the terrorists at this
point, okay? Anybody who has human emotions, human empathy, uh
a set of eyes connected to a
they're unfortunately going to have to stand on the side of the
terrorists on this one, okay? I I'm sorry. That's the way it
is at this point. That's where it's at.
Pretty unambiguously so. I wish it were I wish it weren't this
way. You either want to take out terrorists or you don't. Time
out. Do not play the pick-a-side, Adam, when it comes to
or 20,000 children dead. Don't play that game with me, because
if terrorists were in this loca- almost certainly low, by the
way. this location, Israel should have done Slow down. Slow down.
What do you mean children dead? Adam, you if you show Gaza right
now, and I I don't even want him to show it. Look at what Gaza
looks like. Was there Hamas everywhere? Yeah. Cuz it's flat Okay.
>> THIS IS THE SECOND TIME I WATCH IT, and it all hits
the same amount. It hits just as hard. Look at Look at Gaza RIGHT
NOW. WAS HAMAS EVERYWHERE?
They were everywhere.
Every man, woman, every Palestinian in
was Hamas. Yes, Hamas is everywhere. It's like, dude, are you
Like nobody
th- This is This looks so bad for everybody who supports Israel,
right? This looks awful. This horrible optics. Yes, they were
everywhere. They were everywhere. Every Every man, woman, and
child had to go. Every apartment had to go. Vinny, it all had
to go. Vinny, they were hiding in the hospitals. That's why every
hospital had to go. Don't you understand, Vinny? They were everywhere.
It's so obvious. It's so obvious, man. >> Yeah. Adam, you
if you show Gaza right now, and I I don't even want him to show
it. Look at what Gaza looks like. Was there Hamas everywhere?
[clears throat] Yeah. Cuz it's flat Okay. Well, that's Okay,
by the way, the the whole children and I know we don't want to
talk about this. The whole children dead. Why are children dead?
What do you mean? Because they didn't Because when you throw
quadcopter through the wind and you don't do a ground invasion,
go in the tunnels and you go at everybody, you could just carpet
bomb everybody and just say, "Well, there's terrorists there."
>> one quick question follow up. Yeah. Where are these
children hanging out? Oh, what do you mean, Adam? This is They're
got They live there. They live >> They by themselves? They
hanging out on the blocks with their Oh, they're with their parents.
>> Yeah. Gotcha. So, they're with their parents who are
basically
part of Hamas. Also all the parents Is that your argu-
>> it's so insane.
IT'S SO INSANE. NOW YOU SEE WHY I'M WATCHING THIS TWICE. IT'S
SO
OH, YEAH? WELL, what do their parents do?
Their parents are with Hamas, aren't they? He's saying it so
calmly. THIS MAKES IT SO MUCH MORE PSYCHOTIC, by the way. The
calm voice. If you're emotional in saying this, if you're Ethan
Klein-ing it and just losing your mind, getting totally histrionic
in your feelings, and you're like yelling this at somebody, it
hits a little different. At least that's like from a place of
defense. The cold, dispassionate, "Yeah, those kids are with
their parents who are in Hamas." It sounds psychotic.
It sounds insane.
Dude, Oh, what do you mean, Adam? This is They're got They live
there. They live there. >> They by themselves? They hanging
out on the blocks Oh, they're with their >> Yeah. Gotcha.
So, they're with their parents who are >> Dude, Vinny.
Vinny.
Vinny like sees a demon before him. Vinny actually is seeing
like horns. Like he is seeing Baal
before him right now. Vinny is like literally
getting thrown through a loop. Vinny is like pleading from a
human perspective. Like he he is like, "Dude, you can't be saying
this. You Adam, please."
You have to under- You you're Adam, what are you arguing?
It's It's Dude, it's what? are basically
part of Hamas. Dude, he's He's like He looks like he's ready
to cry. I'm not even joking. He looks ready to cry. >> themselves?
They hanging out
He's like He's He's going through it. He's like actually just
going through
Yeah, I I think Adam, because this is like usually you have to
go to Israel and meet like a lot of the like actual
like fairly genocidal
like extremists who live there to get this level of like just
total disconnect from humanity in terms of like how you treat
Palestinians or Arabs in general. Um or sorry, Muslims in general.
But Adam's somehow imported it. You don't really get this in
the US that much. This is Adam's like truly in spirit spiritually
Israeli. There's nothing more spiritually Israeli than what Adam
is engaging in right now. It's crazy. He's like, "Oh, shit."
He's like directly channeling Naftali Bennett. hanging out on
the blocks with their Oh, they're with their parents. Gotcha.
So, they're with their parents who are basically
part of Hamas. Also all the all the parents Is that your argument?
Is that all these kids that died, these innocent children, their
parents are Hamas? Are you serious right now? >> Vinny,
I feel like we're going back years to have an argument. Let's
move on. Where No, no, let's not move on. Let's stay right here.
Vinny Vinny is like, "Okay, this guy's crashing out. We need
to save his career. He's saying totally insane shit." Dude, everybody
It's a universal experience.
It's a universal experience. Adam is a joke. Old Vinny coming
back. Adam is a joke. Oh my god, this guy is disgusting. Vinny
W. Vinny W. Adam is a bozo. Adam, get out. Adam is garbage. Adam
is honestly disgusting. I thought we lost Vinny. Good to see
you back. Cut Adam's mic. Vinny's Oh, there's one guy. Vinny
is embarrassing. Clown emotes. Adam is an idiot or he's a Mossad
agent. Demon. It's universal. This is the universal
This is the same video. This is the same video. The universal
reaction is like, "This is demonic." And Vinny tries to cut it.
Vinny is like, "Dude, we can't even have this argument. You are
saying insane things that you will not be able to walk back.
You actually won't be able to walk these things back."
Hamas is embedded in society.
So, kill everybody is your thing. Just No, why Why they take
so long? What do you mean kill everybody? If they wanted to kill
everybody, there'd be a million people dead right now.
You have to understand.
If they wanted to They want to kill everybody. They're held back
by the rest of the world. There's only so As As we can see already,
there's only so much evil you can do before the rest of the world
turns on you. That's what they're limited by. The morality of
every other human, not
They are beyond morality at this point. They will do anything
they can. They will harm these people in any way they can. They
are actually demonic.
And the only thing holding them back is whether or not it's effective
or convenient or economical to do so. Okay? That's That's where
it's at. That's how we all have to evaluate it, which is another
reason that freaking out over this and trying to say like, "Hey,
this is really bad. It's getting really bad." is important. It's
important you do that. It's important everybody knows about this
and has an opinion on it and takes the correct side on it, because
the only thing restricting Israel's actions are the rest of the
world and the consequences that you are going to present them
for those actions.
to kill everybody, which they don't, a real genocide, there'd
be a million people dead in Gaza. Do you know that? The fact
that they're talking about only 60,000,
half of which are Hamas, half of which are civilians,
is a testament to the fact that they don't want to kill everybody.
>> America killed how many people in Iraq? How many people
Guys, the By the way, this is just Adam's doing a little bit
of a different argument, but it's like, dude, the how many people
did the Nazis kill? They killed so many people. It's like, okay,
that doesn't get you
He talks about America and Iraq. America and Iraq at the start
is absolutely
Right? Absolutely monstrous.
but that doesn't help. America has literally apologized.
I believe Obama himself has said, "This was a mistake. We should
never have done
It's It is not okay what America did in
And yes, it can't be okay. Oh, Bush said that. Well, oh, Bush
has said that, too. Yeah. The like everybody understands that
this was
Everybody gets it. And Adam is sitting here being like, dude,
America did like something close to genocide, no? People in Afghanistan
>> And it it was all wrong. >> And I never heard
the word genocide >> mean? Adam I left the military because
of what we did in Iraq. I, Vincent Oshana, left cuz of 9/11 and
Iraq. Okay, let me get to this next story. Here's the story I
want to get >> I I don't understand your PBD's trying to
Vinnie already called it off once, and then Vinnie got baited
back into the argument. Now PBD's trying to call it off, okay?
So, that's two times they're trying to end this. PBD's going
to next story. I'm going on to the next story, guys. We're not
going to do this anymore. We're going on to the next story. What's
your point? I Adam, how I don't I don't understand your point.
You don't understand that he's saying he finds it monstrous?
That he's saying it was morally objectionable?
This is By the way, Vinnie's in the wrong room. Vinnie, I I hate
to tell Vinnie this. I I don't know how to explain this to you.
True sales people are total psychos, like actual psychopaths
who don't feel empathy for other people. And Adam is like that.
Adam is that person. Vinnie feels empathy. Vinnie, you are trying
to connect with this person on an empathetic level. He is a lizard.
He will never be able to connect with you that way. That's why
he can't understand you. There's no language you can speak to
him in. Okay? He is an alien. You can't speak to him.
Lots of people on the right wing, I do believe you could reach.
There are certain people, and this is sales people, especially
people who are involved in MLMs and They are disconnected
from other humans
in a way that you you won't be able to communicate this this
way. The suffering, you won't be able to use other people's plight
to move them in any way.
>> let me get to this next story. Here's the story I want
to get >> don't understand your point. I Adam, how I don't
Let him go to the next story. This is the story >> Adam
What point?
>> Dude, Vinnie is like about to Vinnie's about to tweak
out of his shoes.
Adam, let him go to the next story. Adam, you got to stop. Adam,
I'm very scared of the thing that's I'm very scared of what what's
wearing your skin right now. I'm very scared, Adam. We need to
stop. Vinnie is like having literal hallucinations. He literally
sees the demon that Adam is. And he's like, Adam, you have to
stop. Adam, you have to stop. Adam, Adam. I don't understand
your point. Here, hold on. Adam, how I don't Let him go to the
next story. But what do you mean
All right, we got to wait for Vinnie to pop back up.
Dude, he is like actually about to cry. Like And Vinnie is like
actually
And I understand the emotion because he's saying like, dude,
we can't we can't keep giving excuses. But he's actually This
is By the way, I don't judge this. I'm I'm just pointing it out
that this is what Adam has no emotion back towards. If any of
you guys had ever gone in, you know, we we famously is is a Destiny
adjacent community got very mad at Hassan for not respecting
Ethan's emotions during that conversation, right? That Ethan
was getting emotional and Hassan wasn't really connecting with
that. I went back and watched. I don't know if that's true. But
this is that happening right now, right? Vinnie is like losing
it. Vinnie is like actually getting emotional, and Adam is like
trying to continue the argument. Vinnie's tried to stop it. PBD's
tried to stop it now. Adam wants to keep it going. I don't understand
your point. Adam. Adam.
I got to listen to it one more time at regular speed. >> Adam
What point? Explain the point. What point is this? >> We're
fighting radical terrorism. And your point is what? >> point
is And your point and I'm pointing I'm saying from a tactical
point of view, they the way that they've handled Gaza Vinnie,
respectfully, let him ask P as question. Yeah. Let him answer
P as >> He's doing it. What was the question? What He answered
the question. That was asking what your point was. I don't know
why this this guy wasn't paying attention.
Adam's point was we're fighting radical Islamist Jihad.
That's what we're That's what we're fighting right now, Vinnie.
And which side are you going to take? Again,
which side are we going to take? Well,
let me tell you about it. Let me tell
What do you know
about our lord about our savior Ali? What do you know about Ali?
Have you heard of Ali?
I said, okay, keep going. Clapping time. Yeah, he was doing >> I thought
you were asking him to explain
And we were trying to >> No, no, I'm asking Bottom line
is this. Whether you like it or not, the world, specifically
the Middle East, has one major problem, brother. You know what
that is? No Christ.
Oh, God.
Boy, boy, howdy is that ironic. Boy, howdy is that That's a crazy
thing to say with no sense of irony at all. The world, specifically
the Middle East, has one major problem, brother. You know what
that is? No Christ. No Jesus >> No, it's the truth. No
Christianity, none of this would be happening if they were all
believers in Christ. >> Sure. Great. Got you. But they
believe in radical Islam. So, you just went to to Christ. They
believe in Allah. And they believe that they're going to reach
paradise when they kill and maim and convert people or die. So,
you're going to have a choice of whether you're going to say,
"Huh, I really don't like to see innocent people dying. Nobody
wants that. Or I'm going to let the radicals take over." I'm
fully on the point of we're not letting them take over. You're
kind of still straddling the middle, respectfully. Well, we got
to take them out, but we can't kill innocent people. That's a
problem. We need Christ. Buddy, at some point you're going to
have to realize this is the problem, and Israel and the United
States is addressing it. >> You think Israel's the problem
or Islam's our problem? Islam's our
PBD, wait, do you think Israel's the problem? No. You can see
where PBD's head was going, right? When Adam asked what the problem
was, there's one problem in the Middle East, and PBD's head immediately
went one place, and Adam's went to a different place, okay? I
think tactically, the way they're doing missions is not For instance,
is it okay If they want to If you want to kill two terrorists,
are you Vinnie's saying the lack of Christ is the problem. Adam
said it's radical Islamic terrorism, radical Islamic Jihad.
You okay with them taking down an entire apartment complex that
people are living in? I don't think Pat I think tactically, send
in your ground troops. Mossad is dope I the IDF and all them,
they don't want to get involved on the ground, which I think
Pat you'll save civilians. >> a very No, I think put some
troops in there. Put some Throw some troops on the ground.
We're oversimplifying a very complicated
I've heard that explanation that it's nuanced and you don't understand
it, and it's like really hard to to Yeah, I get
But unfortunately, you know, once once Gaza look how it look,
it's not nuanced anymore, right? You can only hide in the nuance
for as long as you can like avoid people seeing the totality
of the situation. And once people see the totality of the
well, unfortunately, you you can't really lie anymore. You can't
say it's nuanced anymore cuz it's not nuanced. That place is
a parking lot.
Ain't no nuance there. I'm going to fight the war. Throw some
troops on the ground. You don't just carpet bomb it. >> way,
I'm defending America here, but I just feel like giving you some
facts, brother. How many people do you think live in Israel?
There's 350 million people in America, 350 million. There's a
billion plus in Iran >> Joe Rogan. Joe Rogan. Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan. There's a billion plus in China. How many people do
you think live in Israel? What's your number?
5 million? 5 million? It's 10 million people. That's the size
By the way, the point of that is to think that Israel has outsized
influence or something. So, you realistically, if Vinnie's not
overshooting it, he's winning cuz that's the whole point. A billion
in China, I thought he said. Did he say a billion in Iran? I
didn't hear it. Mul- Multiple people heard >> billion plus
in China. How many people do you 350 million people in America,
350 million. There's a billion plus in Iran I'm in in in India.
There's a billion plus in Corrects. Corrects to India. You means
India. How many people do you think live in Israel? What's your
number?
5 million? 5 million?
It's 10 million people. That's the size of a of a city in
I know people in the IDF. You think they want to be at war? How
many How many tours have you done? What do you mean tours? I
was just in the Air Force. >> you weren't even a tour.
I know people on their fifth tour, seventh tour. They've been
in They've been in Lebanon. They've been [clears throat] in Gaza.
They've been flying to Iran. Dude, you have no idea. My uncle
was in the SS, and you have no idea the grueling effort it took
to pull the lever to make that gas flood into that room every
day, okay?
It was a lot of work. Do you have any idea what war's like? Do
you have any idea how difficult it is to pull that lever every
single day? Yeah, I don't care, Adam. I literally don't. You
can't You can't convince me to care. You cannot You cannot use
this analogy to convince me to care. I'm sorry.
off. There's They don't have enough
The whole conversation about sending boots to Iran, they don't
have enough people. You know, the famous situation with Joe Rogan?
He goes, "How many How many do you think there are in the He
goes, "I don't know, a billion?"
He goes, "Let me Let me lower my expectations.
Half a billion people." I I did see I know the Haaretz article
you're talking about, very specific. And it is basically like,
instead of like normal PTSD, people are like coming home and
like just having I mean, it's I guess it's PTSD, but it's basically
like PTSD from the war crimes they're witnessing.
Like that it is so normal to go and like just kill families to
loot their [__] And like look families in the eye
while you're mowing them down, that these people are like having
trouble settling their souls. Like their souls are
their their the rest of their essence. Like they've chipped it
away so much that it no longer fits the human
Right? They distinguish it and call it a moral injury. Yes, it's
like not PTSD from seeing your friends die. It's PTSD from the
things you've watched your friends do. I think it was uh Gad
Saad that said, uh >> try 15 million.
I was about 5 million that live in the United States, 10 million
that live in Israel. There's not that many of them. There aren't
10 million that live in
Okay, he's just doing bad math. >> of Israel are Arabs
that are citizens that fight also in the IDF. So, this whole
concept of a boots on the ground where you think all these people
are going to be everywhere at They don't have the numbers.
That's just the bottom line. And you have these 10 million people,
which very few, less than half a million are actually serving,
that are fighting war after war after war after war, and we're
saying do more. They're to their last leg.
They're spamming APAC Adam in the chat right now. APAC Adam,
nobody cares Adam. Bro, cut his mic. Bro, cut his mic.
And America comes in as a capable ally We NEED DAVE SMITH.
>> WHERE'S OUR HERO? WE NEED A HERO. We need We need our
hero. Where's Dave Smith? Get Dave Smith in here. With Israel
in the Middle East >> to get to this next story. >> to defeat
Islamic terrorism. Trump warns China Dude, PBD just cut him.
PBD did did just cut his mic. PBD goes, "Hey, okay. All right,
we're getting to this next story." This guy won't shut the [__]
up.
Like Adam Adam Adam tried to hit him with the empathy. Have emp-
empathy for the IDF soldiers who are getting really tired of
of mowing people down, okay?
Have empathy for the IDF soldiers who can't handle the thoughts,
the the nightmares of their friends mowing down families with
kids
intentionally in front of them, and then they know that if they
ever go to the courts about it, they're going to be like lambasted
and destroyed politically, economically. Their lives will be
over. So, they can't report it. They just have to sit there and
pretend they didn't see it, or pretend it didn't happen. But,
they can't pretend it didn't happen because their the souls of
the people they watched victimized will haunt them for the rest
of their lives. There is no escape. There's no escape in this
world for them, okay? They will have to live with that forever.